[Music]  could i ask you to respect my children's  space  [Music]  princess of wales is dead after a car  crash in paris they were apparently  being pursued by paparazzi on two  motorcycles  [Music]  i was one of the last four or five  people that she called  what did you talk about  it dealt a lot with um the publicity  that had sort of surrounded those last  uh days and weeks of her life and she  she knows she talked about how fed up  she was now i had heard this before but  this time i felt she really meant it she  talked about leaving the country she  talked about going to america settling  there  [Music]  well there were three of us in this  marriage so it was a bit crowded  a legacy of course is mainly  rests in the shape of her sons what  would she make of the fact that they had  this falling out i think that uh while  she's still with us  there would have been no split between  harry and william  [Music]  you